cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com I want to address this
because we got some Florida men here you
know the judge said that Mar-A-Lago is
worth around 18 to 20 million dollars
and this is 17.5 Acres of beach to beach
Palm Beach property now I don't know
what kind of place you're you're living
in Dave yeah however whatever you must
have bought living down here it's got to
be worth based on the judge's estimate
50 bucks 100 bucks something like that
so
um it's completely and so let me just
say clearly because I've hit Trump a lot
lately and I got a lot of Mag angry I
mean all of these cases are pure
this one is the height of
because it has nothing to do
with anything political it's purely to
destroy the man right and the crazy part
about this is if you if really the the
goal of all of these things was to get
him out of politics you'd have to leave
him with something you got to leave him
with his businesses so he can get out
right so the idea that they're going
after him on this oh and also you know
when you buy a house you've bought
properties when you buy a house you
don't just you can't just make up a
number this house is worth 40 million
dollars you get an appraiser there is a
system in place and it all depends right
if you don't want to sell and someone
comes to you and says I want to buy your
property I think you say sure but the
the idea so it's 17 and a half acres in
West Palm Beach no no it's just easily
not West Palm Beach I made the same
mistake oh it's in Palm Beach proper
right right Beach to beach yeah have you
been there I've been there like it's
it's a little bit kind of getting old
and they could fix up a lot of stuff and
it's probably not worth what Trump wants
it to be worth but it is easily easily
worth 80 million dollars there is no
state agent no no I'm saying at the bare
minimum probably closer to like 120
something like that way more um I don't
know about that
for 20 million dollars yeah but you have
to remember the market and you still and
you have to find someone that can buy
the thing so it can be worth something
sort of in our minds but someone that
really at this point with interest rates
the way they are and everything else
that would buy yeah I think the point is
it's not 18. neither one of us know if
they there's 100 if they section this
thing off acre acre lots yeah he's
getting he's going to get 300 400
million for it but I don't know that
he's just dead acreage right yeah
there's some covenants requiring it to
remain historically or something like
that which does diminish the value but
right now the the there's a house next
door that is a third acre for and it's a
substantially obviously the house
property is substantially smaller 30
some odd million dollars right insane
insane the guy's easily off 100 million
I think we could say that like so I
think I think when you add the fact that
it's a business yeah that it generates
25 million per year is the is the
estimated Revenue combined with the real
estate the tennis courts and all of that
you've got a functioning business at 25
million dollars if you just had a
business that that ran at 25 million
dollars You could argue your business
worth 250 million why so so here's the
here's the way I phrase it because Kyle
kalinsky made this post where he was
ragging on Trump saying it's not worth
this it's worth 70. that guy's still
doing it he went nuts on this one okay
and he said it's it's it's it generates
25 million per year it's worth at most
75 million dollars all you got to do is
break it down this way forget the real
estate value which is 17 and a half
Beach to beach acres in Palm Beach okay
let's do say a business let's say you
have a business that makes 25 million a
year and someone comes to you and says
you you make 25 million dollars every
year okay I'd like to buy this off you I
think it's worth 75 million your
response is going to be so what you're
paying me two years up front to sell my
right for the rest of my life 20 25
million a year that's the stupidest deal
I've ever heard maybe 10x if he says 250
million you're thinking like I get nine
years of work up front with that money I
can do a lot of things so if you go to
Trump and you say minus the real estate
it's only 75 million absolutely insane
you add that business on to it you add
the 17.5 I think Trump's assessment
might have is it is it 400 to 600 might
have been a little low depending on on
on on how you want to imagine it because
if you were to break it apart you could
argue that value but the but the crazy
thing about the story is they're arguing
in this fraud case against Donald Trump
in New York and in Florida that he
undervalued his property to get
favorable or overvalues his property to
get more money on loans
that's that's the opposite of what
people do with fraud they they say their
properties worth less so they pay less
in taxes it would also be the fault of
the bank right like most people get
loans when you get when you buy you buy
a house for a hundred thousand dollars
you might put 20 grand down you get an
80 000 loan but the bank comes in and
appraises it they don't they don't just
magically you can't just write a number
out and be like give me cash so yeah
this is this thing is all complete
nonsense uh the fact that so there's not
going to be a jury trial you heard this
they're not going to be a jury trial
because apparently his lawyer forgot to
check a box on the phone I don't know I
don't know I don't know about that
you don't have a jury of your peers in
New York City right you have a whole
bunch of crazy leftists that will of
course automatically no matter what
happens no matter what evidence is
provided automatically to say Trump bad
Trump jail well someone could double
check it but I think they're now a
fitness that's what they're saying that
that they didn't check a box right
that's what's going to happen either
Trump's lying or the judge is lying I
think the strategy here ask yourself why
would Donald Trump actually show up for
this court case when the judge already
is in a summary judgment dissolve living
the Trump organization they want to file
an appeal so they don't want to waste
their time with the jury that's
pointless it's going to cost them more
money all that stuff's a waste of time
they get their ruling run it through
file the appeal get the lower court get
the lower court reversed yeah that's
what I think is happening as well
because it doesn't make sense to have a
jury trial the judge is going to be
deciding here we saw a video of him
today and he uh clearly really likes the
camera really likes the Limelight but
but with all of this happening here just
to take a step back there's politicians
that literally killed American teenagers
there's politicians that go to Jeffrey
Epstein's Island and you're telling me
we're going after this guy because he
over inflated the property value that he
had what this is after investigating him
for so long this is what you have on
them are you freaking kidding me I will
say this you get these these Democrat
types that are like we are holding
people accountable I mean are you saying
you don't want accountability my
response is if you come to me and say I
can choose between investigating
Epstein's Client List and Donald Trump
overvaluing his homes I say I don't care
about Trump's homes please investigate
actions clientless they still have not
released this they're still not doing
anything related to it but oh boy
they're mad about Trump the price of
Trump's properties how many years ago
did this freaking happen this is
ridiculous this is stupid this is not in
the public interest and this is clearly
the weaponization of the justice system
to destroy I have an idea to clean this
thing up I have an idea to clean this
thing up the Tim Cast Operation is going
pretty well you got like 87 businesses
you really you gotta you got a skate
park indoors you're doing a lot of stuff
let's find out about this 18 mil Tim
cast moves the operation down to Florida
you run into the thing if we can get
Mar-A-Lago for 18 million dollars done
deal I will take I will take a half a
billion dollar property for 18 million I
better go to any bank and build this on
it for 18 million so they're gonna be
like I will finance oh you said 18
billion or 18 million go ahead go for it
do you think are they giving you the
just the flat land value appraisal when
they said 17 they're not even accounting
for there's no such thing like not right
right not that because otherwise it
would be a complete teardown I don't
know if anyone's making that art I got
an idea I have an idea here's what
here's here's my proposal to counter
Democrats I I say we all give Donald
Trump blanket immunity if he releases
all the Epstein information and launches
an investigation into everything I I
will I will go as far to say I will I
will uh uh I will give give Trump a full
pardon on literally anything he has
anything he's ever done if they actually
investigate and bring out the
information that I've seen and and you
might be saying why would the Democrat
yeah that's a double loss yeah but I'm
saying Trump does when he gets elected
when Trump gets elected my pitches I
think the American people should all
just agree yeah Trump we're going to
sign this document all the American
people agree you are immune for any past
wrongdoing ever done it's gone you are
immune okay and now go after Epstein and
you may be saying but what if what if
Trump's on the Epstein list what if what
if he's involved I'll be like we we what
if he committed some very serious crimes
or fraud you're gonna let him get away
with all that absolutely we go to drug
lords and gang bangers all the time and
say we know you did this evil thing but
we're gonna make you a immune if you if
you expose the leaders and the people
facilitating this so I whatever you
think of Donald Trump my point is this
when they come out and they're like we
want to hold Donald Trump accountable
for crimes I mean you're not saying you
want him to get away with it are you
black bro I will let him get away with
it I will clap for me having done it if
it means they go after the real
criminals if it means they go after the
people who were trafficking children
yeah absolutely do you think the world
would be a better place and assuming
both of these would make it better if
the hunter Biden the bidens were
completely exposed globally and everyone
knew or if Epstein and Guillain were
globally exposed and everyone knew
that's a good question that's a good
question they're probably connected
absolutely because I've seen it doesn't
just go after the Democratic families he
also goes after the entire establishment
he also goes after the entire banking
sphere which was involved here as we
know from the latest JP Morgan
settlement that happened as of course JP
Morgan spent tens of millions of dollars
trying to settle this out of court when
in reality the the facts of how they
were complicit here is absolutely mind
boggling you have to understand that the
American government for over 30 plus
years used your tax dollars evaded and
used and abused this system to traffic
and hurt thousands of children some of
them as young as seven years old with
your money this is ridiculous this is
inferiorating there's so much corruption
and when you look at that Epstein thing
it he doesn't just go after the puppet
Biden family he goes after everyone
involved here and there were a lot of
different people a lot of celebrities a
lot of banksters a lot of people behind
the scenes that we're not even aware of
as of course Biden here he's just a
flesh suit that the globalists are using
to screw you over I got the vibe that
Epstein was one of the Lane's boys and
that she has a bunch of those dudes and
he was just the one that got caught
because he's an idiot or he just went
too far and but she's like the the
Kingpin like the the linchpin well where
is the list where is the list right what
a judge it's sitting in a locked box
somewhere with the judge there's a lot
of information kept away from the
general public that judges are saying is
is too too controversial for the general
public to find out about and therefore
needs to be kept away from the people
finding out so they'll be a Freedom of
Information Act at some point what 30
years from now and everyone's dead or
amazing
just like they do with the JFK files
that still aren't released 60 70 years
yep six maybe even then I I think we
have to understand here the government
will never tell us the truth and we have
to always imagine the worst and then
times that 10 because it's probably a
lot worse than what we could even
imagine what really happens behind the
scenes because with the Epstein stuff
we're still just scratching the surface
to how corrupt and utterly disgusting
this entire system is and uh there's
another article here that was just
published by The Daily Mail showing uh
just the true depths of this corruption
that is titled Senator Diane Feinstein's
death leaves her daughter wrangling over
breathtaking 102 million dollar property
fortune and 62 million dollar private
jet she used to visit her Manchester
United
four what's her daughter's name let me
look that up I feel I feel so bad for I
mean you're minding your own business
one day power of attorney over your
Senator mom and then you wake up to
inherit 150 million properties the
amount of work she's gonna have to do no
it's a lot of work she's gonna be in
meetings with lawyers oh I just feel so
bad for her inheriting this this vast
vast swath of Scrooge McDuck like wealth
when when Diane when Diane Feinstein got
into the senate in 1826 what were they
paying at the time does anyone know what
was the salary it was food yeah what
what year did you know for real what
year did she get in she's been in well
she was the mayor of San Francisco but
what year did she get in the Senate
probably 82 something like that like
what were they paying at the time
because the mayor of San Francisco
wasn't paying much maybe she had a
little family money but oh 100 maybe a
hundred million bucks on the plane
I'll look into it yeah let's get some
numbers how many children do you have to
hurt to acquire that money that's what
that's what people should be asking
themselves with these politicians
because that's that's what did she sell
what did she do I'll tell you what she
did what she did was
what happens is a bill is introduced and
it says something like we're going to
ban widgets widget company comes by and
says hey this is really bad for us it's
going to cost a lot of jobs we don't
want widgets banned and then the
politician's like oh but they're going
to introduce us onto the floor which is
going to cause a stock to drop so they
put a bunch of put options on widgets
the bill gets introduced stock truck
stock price goes down they cash out then
they say no we're not going to vote on
this one it's gone and then the price
goes back up what's the uh isn't there
some crazy uh percentage that Nancy
Pelosi has played the market at like she
trades better than 900 of all the day
Traders or something like that whatever
90 it's it's so it's something like
really like 900. literally by like 900x
like it's so someone could check me on
that but like how the hell did she
become worth all this money how did
Gavin become worth all this money all of
them right it's like that's why they
want to get in Congress they're like
it's it's just for if you're a day
trader and you want to get rich you get
into Congress and then you're rich yeah
find time 30 years in Congress she
joined in 92 1992 82 130 000 salary
their salary from 130 is now up to 174.
right so yeah
you put your salary 30 years you put
your your million dollars taxes or your
80k for taxes into a savings account a
high yield and then with compounding
interest after 30 years you have 150
million dollars yeah you could yeah it
depends which way they carry the one I
think right thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time